[Música]
en afganistán los talibanes aún no
anuncian su nuevo gobierno mientras
siguen los combates en la provincia de
panshir el último bastión de la
resistencia armada contra los islamistas
y por su parte qatar anunció el envío
diario con ayuda humanitaria en momentos
en que centenares de afganos siguen
huyendo del país
con gases lacrimógenos en la policía de
montenegro dispersó a cientos de
personas que protestaban en contra de la
investidura de un clérigo de la iglesia
ortodoxa serbia que será el líder
religioso de esa nación una ceremonia
que ha dejado al descubierto profundas
divisiones sobre los lazos con serbia
y la peor sequía en décadas ha sigue
causando estragos en brasil con los
niveles de agua más bajos del último
siglo en las hidroeléctricas el gobierno
se ha visto obligado a pedir a sus
ciudadanos que reduzcan el consumo de
energía
muy buen día para todos gracias por
continuar con nosotros en france 24 0
blanco como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos y comenzamos en afganistán
donde los talibanes continúan demorando
el anuncio de su nuevo gobierno mientras
el aeropuerto de la capital kabul
aumenta los vuelos nacionales
paralizados desde la victoria talibán
desde el pasado 15 de agosto y que solo
pero con vuelos de evacuación hasta el
lunes pasado fecha en la que salieron
del país las últimas tropas
estadounidenses entretanto el embajador
de qatar en afganistán se ha living
murabak athar afirmó que su país enviará
un avión al día con ayuda humanitaria
sobre todo de alimentos y suministros
médicos y es que ante esta crisis
centenares de afganos han cruzado la
frontera hacia pakistán para huir del
gobierno talibán y el colapso económico
que enfrenta a esa nación sin embargo en
pakistán atraviesan otro tipo de
dificultades como por ejemplo la pobreza
y la falta de vivienda el gobierno
paquistaní aseguró que no ha visto
cruces masivos de afganos en la
fronteras pero dijo haber incrementado
la seguridad para evitar que más
personas ingresen a su territorio veamos
el informe
esperaban encontrar seguridad en
pakistán pero esta familia afgana
todavía no ve el fin de sus problemas
los 38 integrantes de la familia huyeron
de la guerra en la provincia de helmand
y llegaron a pakistán a través del cruce
chamán
ahora viven en una tienda medio
derrumbada
la guerra era feroz huimos de la guerra
con nuestros hijos dejando atrás
nuestras casas nuestro ganado nuestras
pertenencias y entramos a pakistán o
patata más más aquí estamos entre ruinas
y tiendas deshechas
a cargo del ballet
las autoridades paquistaníes aseguran
que sus fronteras están cerradas a todos
los que no tengan los papeles en regla
pero centenares de afganos han cruzado
por el pasaje de samán más al norte hay
otro punto de entrada pakistán en tor
jan
del lado afgano este punto está
resguardado por los soldados talibanes
mientras que el lado paquistaní también
ha aumentado su seguridad
oficialmente hay 14 millones de
refugiados afganos en pakistán islamabad
quiere evitar un fenómeno de migración
masiva
durante los últimos años pakistán ha
construido una valla de 4 metros de
altura para reforzar una frontera porosa
y protegerse de la inestabilidad de sus
vecinos
las naciones unidas ha advertido que
medio millón de afganos podrían dejar su
país hasta final de año y si no llega
más ayuda humanitaria la situación
podría empeorar
continuamos en pakistán a donde al menos
tres personas murieron y otras veinte
resultaron heridas en un atentado
suicida encontrar un puesto de control
de las fuerzas de seguridad de la ciudad
de queta ubicada al oeste del país el
principal grupo talibán paquistaní
reivindicó este ataque el ministro
paquistaní el primer ministro pakistaní
imran khan condenó el atentado suicida
de ofrecer sus condolencias de las
familias de los fallecidos que está es
la capital de la provincia de public
están una de las regiones más
conflictivas de pakistán con la
presencia de grupos armados separatistas
facciones talibanes y grupos yihadistas
y al menos 12 policías murieron en un
ataque atribuido al autodenominado
estado islámico en el norte de irak el
ataque estuvo dirigido a la policía
federal general y al rayyan aunque el
estado islámico fue derrotado
territorialmente 2017 tras haber
controlado amplias zonas del país sus
remanentes todavía siguen llevando
ataques sobre todo en contra las fuerzas
de seguridad iraquíes y particularmente
en la frontera con siria y en el norte y
centro del país
las tensiones en montenegro aumentan en
medio de la ceremonia de coronación del
líder de la iglesia ortodoxa serbia en
el pequeño país báltico montenegro está
profundamente dividido alrededor de sus
vínculos con serbia un país vecino del
que se independizó en el año 2006 sin
embargo sus iglesias nunca se separaron
los independentistas trataron de
bloquear la ceremonia que finalmente sí
se llevó a cabo
con rocas de paredes de neumáticos
manifestantes montenegrinos bloquearon
el acceso a la vieja capital de setting
e
intentaban evitar sin éxito la ceremonia
de coronación del nuevo líder religioso
que la iglesia ortodoxa serbia celebró
allí
los manifestantes se enfrentaron a la
policía antidisturbios al grito de esto
no es serbia y viva montenegro
la ceremonia de este domingo exacerbó
tensiones étnicas en el país balcánico
ya que muchos consideran que la iglesia
es un símbolo de influencia a serbia
también se convocaron contra marchas
durante el sábado en podgorica para dar
la bienvenida a los religiosos
estamos escribiendo la historia y
luchando por nuestra fe no le imponemos
nada a nadie solo estamos aquí para
apoyar al patriarca siempre estaremos
con la fe ortodoxa y siempre creeremos
en dios siempre estaremos con nuestra
iglesia nuestra fe y espero que hoy en
la catedral todo transcurra sin
problemas como siempre
montenegro declaró la independencia de
serbia en 2006 pero su iglesia no obtuvo
la autonomía
durante semanas opositores de la iglesia
ortodoxa serbia han pedido que la
coronación se celebra en algún otro
lugar pero la institución religiosa lo
rechazó
el cristianismo ortodoxo es la religión
dominante en el país y los montenegrinos
independentistas quieren una iglesia
propia separada de la serbia
de hecho la iglesia serbia jugó un papel
clave en las manifestaciones que el año
pasado provocaron la caída del gobierno
occidentalista en montenegro el nuevo
gobierno ahora incluye partidos pro
serbios y pro rusos
y hong kong está en la mira
internacional este mes por las
elecciones legislativas que habían sido
aplazadas hace un año y a las que solo
se van a presentar los
progubernamentales tras dejar por fuera
a todos los líderes de la oposición el
voto llegará en un momento en el que las
autoridades de la ex colonia británica
han cerrado varios medios de
comunicación y encarcelado a los líderes
antigubernamentales bajo la
controvertida ley de seguridad nacional
que está en juego en estas
trascendentales elecciones para analizar
este tema nos acompaña guillermo julián
él es columnista y analista
internacional y presidente de la
asociación colombo china gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros el señor puyana
se verá verdaderamente afectada en la
voluntad popular en las urnas el próximo
19 de septiembre cuando no hay
contrincantes a las elecciones del
consejo legislativo en hong kong
no no creo que se vaya a ver afectada
porque además lo que va a pasar mañana
es la continuidad de un proceso político
de 25 años que es cuando los hongkoneses
empiezan a ejercer derechos políticos
inexistentes antes de la reunificación
de 1997
ahora los líderes pro democracia habían
obtenido una mayoría histórica en las
elecciones municipales de noviembre 2019
precedidas para multitudinarias
protestas antigubernamentales fue el
detonante para que china entonces
decidiera acabar de alguna manera con la
oposición
yo creo que el factor esencial que
explica el proceso es la transformación
de ciertas organizaciones políticas con
con esas de
asia hacia movimientos que promovían el
separatismo en hong kong y pues en hong
kong
es un país es un territorio que hace
parte de la república popular china y
por lo tanto pues hay un
derecho de china a mantenerla y hacer
respetar la soberanía nacionales es un
principio de derecho internacional
además reconocido por 178 países del
mundo que tienen relaciones diplomáticas
con china
guillermo con la imposición de una ley
de seguridad de medios de comunicación
independientes cerrados como el apoyo
daily y unas elecciones sin oposición
como quedan las libertades y los
derechos de los ciudadanos en hong kong
a hong kong es una región administrativa
que es muy diversa y que es ampliamente
conectada con el mundo
la ley de seguridad nacional que se
aplica con cómo se aplican las demás
leyes chinas lo que
establece
es que no puede haber
en medios de comunicación que es bajo el
ropaje de la libertad de prensa la
libertad de información lo que hacen es
promover la sedición el terrorismo o la
separación de hong kong digamos ese es
un derecho que ejercen todos los países
del mundo igualmente pero hong kong no
no es
un país es uno en el china no es un país
aislado ir y hong kong no es una región
aislada del contexto de la información
mundial
eso no es correcto digamos no es una
precisión acertada
guillermo gracias por su tiempo por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 que
tengo usted de sufrir resto de ella
nosotros continuamos con más información
porque el presidente de la asamblea
nacional de venezuela jorge rodríguez
quien encabeza a la delegación del
gobierno de nicolás madura en el diálogo
con la oposición que se lleva a cabo en
méxico aseguró que ya es hora de que el
país recupere la libertad económica y
regrese al cauce democrático rodríguez
también precisó que el diálogo con la
oposición ocurre en un ambiente cordial
lo que considero un elemento positivo
estas son las primeras declaraciones
oficiales que se producen desde que se
inició esta mesa de diálogo el viernes
pasado la crisis tiene problemas de
fondo muy graves de un modelo que
fracasó en venezuela y de un modelo que
no reconoce el orden democrático y el
orden constitucional es solo con el
rescate de la institucionalidad
democrática que vamos a poder resolver
los inmensos problemas económicos que
hay en nuestras patrias todas las
garantías económicas que le han sido
cercenadas bloqueadas robadas sustraídas
al pueblo de venezuela esta es una muy
buena oportunidad
que los habitantes y los habitantes de
nuestra patria pues recuperen su derecho
a la libertad económica su derecho a
mantener el cauce constitucional la peor
sequía en décadas sigue causando
estragos en brásil con los niveles más
bajos del último siglo en las
hidroeléctricas el gobierno se ha visto
obligado a pedir a sus ciudadanos que
reduzcan su consumo de energía la
escasez de lluvias de este año está
afectando al abastecimiento de energía a
la pesca y al turismo veamos el informe
que ha preparado alba santana
la escasez de agua se siente cada vez
más en brasil- la peor sequía en décadas
está causando estragos en el sector
hidroeléctrico con los niveles de
reservas más bajos del último siglo el
país se declaró en emergencia hídrica en
mayo y la falta de lluvias ha empeorado
la situación por lo que el gobierno
pidió el miércoles a la población
reducir el consumo de energía una crisis
que ha disparado el precio de la
electricidad en diciembre pague 850
reales pero para ser más exacto 848
reales en la factura de la energía es
email este mes la factura es de mil
doscientos veinte reales utilizando el
mismo número de congeladores sin cambiar
nada
el precio en la energía ha aumentado
mucho es difícil trabajar trabaja brasil
la nación con más agua dulce del mundo
ha perdido el 15 por ciento de sus
superficies de agua desde 1991 con el
cambio climático y la deforestación como
las principales causas de que los ríos
se estén secando hemos perdido el 15 por
ciento de la superficie del agua del
país destacan algunas regiones como el
pantanal el mayor humedal continental
del planeta y el más afectado por el
cambio de dinámica hídrica con una
reducción del 74 por ciento de su agua
un tema delicado para el presidente
bolsonaro que trata los asuntos
climáticos como algo secundario y se
muestra reacio a imponer restricciones
de consumo energético para no manchar su
imagen de cara a las elecciones del 2022
no obstante los expertos advierten que
la sequía podría persistir por meses
vamos ahora con información deportiva
porque hoy culminan en japón los juegos
paralímpicos la clausura tendrá lugar en
el estadio olímpico de tokio aunque la
mayoría de los atletas paralímpicos han
ya abandonado tokio por las medidas
sanitarias que el gobierno determinó
para la realización de este evento
deportivo a causa de la pandemia de kobe
19 se espera que durante la clausura
haya por lo menos algunas
representaciones de cada delegación que
participó el medallero olímpico queda
entonces de la siguiente manera china en
primer lugar por tener más medallas de
oro seguido de reino unido eeuu el
comité paralímpico ruso y en quinto
lugar países bajos
y finalizamos con arte en italia donde
los directores argentinos gastón duprat
y mariano cohn regresaron al festival de
venecia con la comedia competencia
oficial una divertida sátira sobre el
mundo cinematográfico e inspirado en
experiencias personales de su propio
elenco la película está protagonizada
por penélope penélope cruz antonio
banderas- y óscar martínez quienes
brillaron en la alfombra roja
y de esta manera entonces llegamos al
final del informativo en france 24
continué con nosotros para más
actualizaciones noticia muy buen día
para todos
[Música]